我认为这个世界上最危险的关系是男女关系，
最危险的事情是不是这种情况啊，
我我老公呢，
他是一年的话就是50个，
然后我的话是25个，
是我在呃哺乳期的时候，
她就是找了个三儿，
对，
就是很偶尔的情况，
我们在地下车库里面的时候遇到了，
然后碰到这个事情，
然后那个2+1，
她老公也来，
就经历了一个修罗场一样的事情，
然后在那之后的话，
我就看了很多那种关于就是呃，
遇到这种情况你应该怎么去相处的这种的书，
然后就是你不要再提恋爱事，
你还好好生活，
然后我就好好生活，
然后就心里还是有点下不去，
但是我一直对他态度都很好，
我对他父母也很好，
然后把自己的工资啊收入啊什么全全部基本上都贴到家里面，
然后就今年的时候怎么说遇到了一只小男孩九二死一个女明星的一个男生，
是不是啊，
因为就又男啊，
就体验到了刘晓青姐姐的快乐，
然后后面又遇到一个特别聊得来的一起考试的一个男孩子，
然后就是太快乐了，
太开心了，
就想把这个事情处理好嘛，
然后今年的话，
因为我的工作性质的话是比较就是呃GQ就比较偏体质方面的，
所以我现在就是在想，
我现在是嗯，
离了比较好呢，
还是不离比较好，
因为就我先生的话，
她是对孩子很好，
但是他对家里就对我真的是没有什么感情，
就是我怀孕生娃啊什么，
她也基本上就没管，
然后后面的话。
对，
我的收入也比较，
但是他的钱都攒在我这儿，
但是攒的话是只能放着，
就我是不能动这个钱了，
不能花，
但是他会给我，
但离的话我能分很大一部分，
然后他婚前的话没有什么财产，
就是他什么都没有，
然后基本上都是我家这边的，
就以我经济上的话相对比较宽松，
然后长相也还可以，
就像这种情况，
就是我这种工作性质，
就我后面还想就过得比较开心的话，
是离了比较好，
还是就保持健更孩子多大了呀，
3岁，
然后现在是我父母在带，
因为我们工作的话比较偏，
就我们收入高一些，
但是就是工作地方就就相当于在山里边，
男孩女孩呀，
男孩子假设要跟他分开的话，
这孩子是怎么安排的，
肯定对我，
我之前跟他其实在好好聊，
就我跟他聊的时候，
我说我看不开这个事情，
我说人嘛，
就婚姻也不是坐牢，
我说你以后你爱干嘛干嘛，
我也不太管你，
但后面就是反而他有时候会管我，
有说我出去还挺开心的，
然后他打电话不行，
有时候查岗有点烦，
你知道吗？
但是我现在把他们的我父母关系，
包括把他都我觉得关系我都处理的非常好，
就是按着书上说的，
然后就是花钱把他父母也哄好了，
然后反正把他也就是就情绪相处的都还不错，
那他现在就是那件事情，
他在外面找人那件事情，
然后被你撞见了那件事情他之后。
他是一个什么心态，
现在对你们的这个婚姻他就道歉嘛，
然后就那个啥，
因为这是那种挺难看的，
我当时还带着他同事一块去找的他，
然后在地下车库找架了，
就碰到个现场，
然后在那之后就后悔啊或者什么的，
但之后我感觉就是反正就我痛苦啊，
就痛苦有半年多时间，
然后面才慢慢看开了吧，
他这个状态就是不想离业，
要好的生活，
但是他再给我不了啥，
就我现在在想的话，
就确实觉得没啥用，
他的那个工作是铁饭碗吗？
对啊，
我们都非常铁，
还有一个就是我当时拍视频了，
就是我这个话，
我能把他放围给，
所以我觉得他更多的是害怕，
那如果你跟他分开，
你大概能分到多少钱呢？
你能分100吧，
你自己条件也很好啊，
你自己一年能挣，
然后你爸爸妈妈又能帮你带孩子，
像你的这个情况确实是就是进可攻退可守的是吗？
那你现在还爱你老公吗？
咋说呢，
就是作为一个生活搭子还凑合吧，
就是他太抠了，
就这个人怎么说就是很典型的那种男的，
就是真的是又很小气，
又很利己主义，
那他也没有什么别的依靠的那种，
就是他背后没啥人，
就我后面也分析过，
就他就是因为原生家庭确实不好，
他父母是一点爱都没有，
他们整个家庭就是那种吸水性，
他兄弟有3个，
所以就是他父母就很。
生，
我很冷漠，
跟其他关系的话处也不太好，
他背后也为人就我能理解，
但是确实伤害了我了，
那你对你未来的生活是一个什么样的预期呢？
就是还想再生孩子吗？
肯定不生了，
你你爸爸妈妈也是有退休工资的，
是不是啊，
对对对对对，
是有，
那你是独生女吗？
独生女那我感觉你这情况的话，
那就好好的享受人生吧，
我就害怕我这个工作人，
我就万一我说了享受人生是离开她了之后，
自己好好的享受人生，
离开她了之后，
我作为一个单身的离异的一个女人，
我跟学历这块都是属于合法的，
不违背道德的，
我不怕任何人拿着我的把柄，
拿着我的视频，
拿着我的照片，
拿着我的聊天记录，
不害怕任何人，
我之前说口虑，
你现在这个状态的话，
你既害怕你老公发现你，
你又害怕交往的这两个弟弟，
他俩拿这个事儿当成把柄来要挟你，
你的整个人生是属于一种非常恐惧的一个状态的是你看你爸爸妈妈又有退休工资，
爸爸妈妈又能帮你带孩子，
你自己一年能挣25万，
你跟他分手能分100万，
然后你自己又是那么体面的工作，
以后你对自己的未来规划很清晰，
你也不想再生孩子了，
就好好享受。
人身啊，
还有那我想问一个，
这个就是关于我俩的那个抚养费这个东西规定到底有没有就靠谱吗？
这个东西他已经算是算妥协状态，
就过去的话，
我如果抚养费一年给，
呃，
一个月给两个，
我这样说就开始有翻把的可能性，
是这样子的，
如果你说你手上有他的那个把柄，
足以撸掉他的工作，
他现在可能会妥协，
那我觉得咱们也适当的就降低一下这个标准，
就我跟你说，
正常情况下啊，
一般情况下的抚养费他不是的，
男方一年收入有50万就咔嚓上来30%，
不是这么判，
他是先看这个小孩的实际需求，
看这个小孩在哪座城市，
经济水平怎么样，
大概就是跟这个城市的抚养费是持平的，
你就问一下你身边周围那些离过婚的同事，
孩子的抚养费大概能判多少吧？
大概好一点的判3000，
差一点的判2000，
他是这么来的，
他不是说如果他能挣1000万，
我上来就能判300万的抚养费，
不是这个逻辑明白吗？
我个人认为啊，
咱们就是也要为他的将来去考虑，
虽然说你有他的把柄，
但是我们有的时候做人做事的话，
留一线啊，
日后好相见，
我个人觉得他一年收入如果是50万的话，
如果你这头能够一个月要到1万块钱的抚养费就已经很好了，
就是一年。
12万的抚养费，
那么他那一头的话，
他自己还要生活，
他将来还要再婚，
他将来还要再养老婆孩子，
可能他能够就像慢刀子割肉一样，
他能够接纳这个结果，
但如果说你今天你比如说你要的太高了，
你要两万一个月，
干掉他工资的一半，
那他那个50万的话，
只剩下一半，
他还要养家，
当然还要有新的这个老婆和孩子的话，
他可能有一天比如说从你这儿把那个视频删掉了，
他就马上就说这个太高了，
我得重新给你打官司，
我不能给那么高，
明白吗？
嗯，
说个可能会挨骂的话，
到我后面就想在工作的时候还跟他一起说话，
然后这种情况下的话，
你觉得怎么更好一些，
你别老大还想跟他一块儿过多的意思吧，
就是我为想要你还在意他一年能挣50万能给你是这意思，
不过我就感觉跟他日常这种生活，
就我俩现在这个状态，
我还感觉还可以，
就三个都想要，
那这事儿除非你老公他自己也接纳，
当然你有一个离婚证对你是一个保护，
有一个离婚证对你是一个保护，
你不我也不违背什么道德。
其次的话是你老公也同意这样的生活状态，
且你老公那头人家也能找那这个事儿啊，
姐妹啊，
你就当我是多句嘴啊，
不啰嗦，
我认为这个世界上最危险的关系是男女关系，
最危险的事情是乱搞男女关系，
那你的这种情况果三个男人都出现在你生命里的话，
你保不齐万一哪个比如说粘一下弟弟，
他对你动真情了，
因为爱情是排他的啊，
亲密关系是排他的，
他可能会伤害你，
就有他，
我不是跟三个都到那个程度，
然后我就只是精神交流，
就哎，
其实跟朋友差不多，
就可能就聊天聊的比较开心，
就没有啊，
这个有走到内部啊，
真的是龙飞律师，
我自己干那么多年，
我看一下的话，
真的是。
我对每一个姐妹的忠告，
反正从我自己这个角度来说的话，
我认为男女关系这件事情一定要慎重，
我觉得任何一段恋情都不足以让我拿生命和健康作为赌注，
作为代价，
虽然你们家龙飞姐有的时候也是很羡慕自己的这心里的某一个角落，
因为我们作为女人嘛，
总是觉得自己在服异性啊，
或者说在获取异性的那种青睐啊，
追求啊，
在这件事情上，
我觉得我们女人都是会有胜负欲，
会有这个女人的那个，
就自我的那个觉醒吧，
就总希望自己是很吸引人的啊，
因为我自己干这个工作实在看的太多了，
因为爱情这个东西，
它就是玄妙的，
排他的，
激情的，
就是有可能呃，
让人丧失理智的，
可能让人做出很多冲动的行为的。